(gentle spirited music)
- Long continual learning
is one of the core interest topics for me,
and it does relate to both
artificial intelligence
and neuroscience as Alyssa mentioned.
So in a sense,
it's kind of the ultimate
challenge, seems to be these days,
for artificial intelligence systems
to kind of bridge the gap between
the artificial and natural intelligence.
So I will briefly go over
some motivation and history
of the field, which dates
back to 1950s, if not earlier,
as it started in
computational neuroscience,
and inspirations from neuroscience
kind of fueled the research for a while.
And most recently there was an explosion
of different approaches and
settings trying to solve
their lifelong continual
learning problems,
especially in deep neural networks.
I'll also touch upon the
recent most challenging
and exciting area of continual
reinforcement learning.
And we'll conclude this tutorial
with some recent open questions
and perhaps some
controversial discussions,
whether scaling of neural net models
can solve their main issue
of catastrophic forgetting
or maybe something more is needed.
So starting with motivation and history,
well, clearly you're all are
aware of impressive results
achieved by artificial
intelligence systems
in the past decade from playing games,
and beating human champions,
and chess and poker
and stone supports to generating paintings
that actually were successfully sold
at New York art auctions,
using GANs for example,
and definitely achieving
or sometimes beating
a human level accuracy
in detecting abnormalities
in medical imaging,
and to the recent year kind
of really amazing results
in terms of generating text,
which is pretty much indistinguishable
from human written texts
by the GPT-3 system.
And we're all kind of waiting to see
when GPT-4 going to be announced
and what is going to be able to do
by this idea of scaling
modern neural networks,
and training them also on
a humongous amount of data
seem to be bearing fruit
and we see the results
that we were never able to see so far.
But what is recognized still
as one of the major limitations
is a lack of breadth or
versatility in these AI systems,
because they're still
somewhat narrow specialists.
And as you all know,
we humans and ideally artificial
systems we want to build
should be able to be
versatile, multitasking,
and be able to continually
kind of acquire new skills,
and it doesn't necessary
have to be a system
that is best at everything
and beating human champions
in all the games,
but rather we would like to have a system
that may be good enough,
but at extremely broad range of tasks,
just like we humans are.
How do we get there?
How do we achieve this versatility?
So the are typical paths,
there is through lifelong,
or continual learning,
essentially constant expansion
and development of your abilities
and acquiring increasingly
more complex behaviors
building upon what you
learned in the past.
And as I will be talking soon,
also avoiding issue called
catastrophic forgetting.
So examples of practical applications
where artificial systems
will need such versatility
and ability to learn continually
range from classical continual learning
challenge of robotics,
where the robot has to
learn to do new tasks
in new environments and
keep kind of learning
without completely forgetting
what the current day go,
to obviously at systems that
control autonomous vehicles,
and change environment
from country road to the city to highway.
Obviously, systems that maintain
conversations with people,
conversational agents of different kind,
they should be very flexible
because the situations change
in which they supposed
to be helping the person,
and also the person's
mood may be changing.
And even with one person,
there will be a lot of
adaptations required
for just that specific person,
leave alone adaptation
of conversational agents
across different users.
And here is one of my favorite movies,
movie "her" where the
conversational agent turned out
to be extremely flexible
and continually learning.
And examples go on and on,
there are many, of course,
important medical applications
such as medical imaging,
where it's really
important to have systems
that can learn on data from
one hospital for example,
and utilize that data
for different hospitals,
learn continually from patient to patient,
and from disorder to disorder, because,
unfortunately most of the
time in practice right now,
you have to retrain those
systems from scratch
on the new data sets.
But if you believe that
there is something common and
variant about the disorder,
you really would like to
exploited all the data sets that
you will be encountering during
the lifetime of the system
and incorporate that
information in the flexible way.
So what is one of the
key problems identified
with continual learning,
and this, as I said,
dates back to the previous
century of course,
way before more than a large
scale deep neural networks,
the problem was encountered multiple times
in computational neuroscience.
And one most notable paper
was a paper from 1989
by McCloskey and Cohem,
where they demonstrated that
when they train neural network
using backpropagation,
just the classical standard neural map
on the problem of learning
how to do one sums ones,
additional facts, like a
one plus one, two plus one,
three plus one, and so on.
The system can learn it well,
but the moment they switch
to the two addition facts,
it starts forgetting really quickly
what they've learned before
to the point that in a few trials,
performance drops to
like 20% from hundred.
And a few more trials,
and system completely
catastrophically forgets
what it learned before.
So this phenomenon actually
is a part of more general
challenge in both
computational neuroscience,
trying to understand how our
brains adapt to new situations,
how plasticity happens
without losing stability or memory,
and how do we implement that potentially
in artificial neural networks.
So catastrophic interference
or catastrophic forgetting
is just one part of this general issue,
because you need both
plasticity to change quickly
when the environment changes,
but you also need stability,
so you don't forget
what you learned before.
And there is a long history
of continual learning
and this chart is highly
sketchy and incomplete,
so I apologize in advance,
but I tried to put
together at least partially
some points in the history
when terminology was introduced
with particular important
findings were discovered
and it all can be even dated back
to the sensitivity stability trade-off
described by Hebb in 1949,
to the stability plasticity
dilemma that I mentioned
on the previous slide.
And then our various methods
that we're trying to avoid
catastrophic forgetting mainly
developed during nineties
in computational neuroscience literature.
And then most recently
they really were picked up on
in the deep learning community
because once we managed to
achieve those impressive results
with deep neural nets in specific tasks,
the next question was exactly,
"So now how do we learn this
ability to perform at all
and be versatile just
like we humans do it."
So recent five years, I would say,
witnessed exponential growth
in the number of papers
in the continual lifelong learning area.
Talking about neuroscience,
there are, of course,
multiple inspirations that
were used over the past few decades,
but the most notable ones, I would say,
were related to a frequency of thoughts
that I will describe in
the following three slides.
Basically plasticity is, most of the time,
meant to be synaptic.
So when we talk about
plasticity of neural net,
we meant adaptation of synaptic Bates,
and the interesting thing is
that some recent experiments
also kind of support
that earlier hypothesis,
that when we learn a new task,
and in this case it was an experiment
basically looking at the
strings of the synopsis,
looking at the size of our
dendritic spines corresponding
to those when we learn a new task,
some of them get enlarged,
so they correspond to the synapsis
that are kind of taking
care of solving the task,
roughly speaking.
The interesting thing
is that those changes
do persist over like
long time like months.
And we do not forget the tasks we learn,
but if you actually directly intervene
and use some approaches
from synaptic optogenetics,
you kind of revert those changes,
then the task will be forgotten.
So it's really telling you
that certain synapsis will be
responsible for representing
and solving particular tasks,
and therefore you may want
to do something like that,
when you train your deep neuro lab.
You want to dedicate certain weights,
certain connections to particular tasks,
and make sure that you protect
them from being washed out
by more recent training.
And this idea gave rise to
multiple approaches in the past,
including a relatively recent
elastic weight consolidation method
that became quite popular
and kind of gave rise
to many recent approaches,
I'll talk briefly about
that in a few minutes.
But I also want to mention another
kind of quite famous theory
that gave rise to different
computational approaches,
this is called Complementary
Learning Systems theory.
So it also dates back to
'90s to 1995, if not earlier,
and the idea is that we have, kind of,
at least two parts of the memory system,
we have the fast learning hippocampus,
that essentially learns
episodic information.
And then later on it is
consolidated in neocortex,
usually during sleep or arrest
into more structured knowledge
that can be used to generalize
to all kind of new situations.
And this inspired whole
bunch of approaches
in the recent continual
learning literature
that are based on the replay or rehearsal
by analogy with how the
information from hippocampus
is being consolidated during sleep,
and stored in neocortex
by means of replaying
the activations in hippocampus that
were associated with
this particular episode.
So essentially this replay
rehearsal approaches
are quite often used in modern methods
for continual learning
and can be also combined with
various other approaches,
I will give some taxonomy of those.
So finally,
another kind of notable thitd
inspiration from neuroscience
is the one that led, I guess,
to the modern so-called
architectural methods.
This inspiration essentially tells you
that sometimes synaptic
plasticity might not be enough.
And sometimes if the environment changes
drastically and a significant
it might be useful
to expand the architecture of your network
by analogy with so-called neurogenesis,
which even happens in
adult mammals and humans,
particularly adult neurogenesis means
growth and incorporation of
new neurons in specific areas
of the brain, particularly hippocampus.
It's pretty much the only area
where it happens in humans,
and other mammals,
It also may happen in our factory default.
But the bottom line is
that when they are changes
in the environment are
sufficiently significant,
it may pay off to expand your
architecture of your network
and loosely speaking,
that's kind of inspiration to third branch
of modern computational
continual learning methods
I will be talking about.
So the first one, as I mentioned,
based on the synaptic
plasticity and freezing weights
that are responsible for tasks,
lead to various regularization approaches.
The second based on the
separation between slow and fast learning,
hippocampus and neocortex learn to replay,
and then neurogenetic approach has led
to architecture based methods
in continual learning.
Okay.
So let us know go to the brief overview
of the modern supervised
continual learning,
because just like there's
machine learning in general,
the supervised part is
most developed these days,
although there is lots of recent research
in unsupervised continual learning.
And as I will mention
in the most challenging
domain out of those
in continual reinforcement learning.
So here is essentially overview
of the continual learning
setting in supervised problems.
And it's compared to the
Standard Supervised Learning,
in the standard one, as you know,
you take inputs X and the
label Y in the given data set,
you assume that there is one distribution
from which the data will be
coming during training and test.
You learn the model and
during the test time,
you will be tested on samples
from the same distribution.
However, in continual learning,
you have a stream
of potentially different
data distributions
and different tasks,
each associated with
its own set of samples.
So you have those inputs
and outputs X and Ys
coming from distribution one,
then switching to distribution two,
and potentially the infinite stream
of different data distributions.
Your learner acts in online
versus offline manner.
And it has to essentially
learn all those tasks
because each time it may be tested
on all the previous tasks seen so far,
that's why you would
like the method to adapt
to new data sets and still be
able to remember how to solve
the previous ones.
Clearly continual learning
relates to many sub areas
of modern machine learning,
that have in common the same component
of having multiple data distributions
and trying to somehow come up with a model
that can make use of all those data,
and also be able to handle at
least some new distributions.
But multi-task Learning is perhaps
the most classical
baseline kind of comparison
when you given set of data distributions,
but simultaneously, so
learning is offline,
unlike continual learning .
And essentially you can shuffle the data,
which is not an option in
continual online learning.
And you can essentially use one model,
you're trying to train model
with shared set of parameters,
that will work well
on all these different
tasks simultaneously.
During the testing you
will be given samples,
again, coming from
distributions of those tasks,
but nothing out of distribution.
So there is no continual
model on adaptation here,
it's offline approach.
Okay. So let me...
So transfer learning is another
kind of closely related,
but simpler setting where you
typically have source tasks
and target task to data distributions.
And you try to transfer
knowledge from the model learned
on the first task to perform
better on the second task,
but you don't really care
about keeping the performance
on the first task.
Again, there is no
continuous adaptation here,
after you learned the target task,
there is no online infinite
stream of changing environments.
And as I mentioned,
the source task performance
doesn't matter anymore,
once you transfer you kind
of knowledge to that new one.
Domain adaption is also
closely related of course,
so it's kind of a particular
case of transfer learning
where the source and
target task are the same,
but the input domains are different.
Again, same comparison
with continual learning,
this is unidirectional,
you do not accumulate knowledge
in the infinite stream,
and you do not really
care about performance
on the previous data sets,
after you transfer
knowledge to the new ones.
Finally, are kind of most popular recently
and kind of rich area of
this type of multitask
and multi environment
learning is meta-learning.
And there are many
methods developed recently
to solve these type of problems,
but the setting is, again, offline.
You assume that there is
a certain distribution
of distributions of the tasks.
You draw a set of different data sets
from this distribution.
Each data set belongs to
its own data distribution,
and you must train single model,
so that during the test time,
when it will be presented with yet another
new data distribution,
not something you've seen
on the training time,
it will be able to do well on it.
It will be allowed to adopt
in a few short kind of manner.
So you're really trying to learn a model
that can be easily
adopted to a large variety
of different new datasets,
of course there's certain assumptions
of how they relate to the old data sets
on which you're trained.
Again, the problem here as
compared to continual learning
is that we're learning offline.
We have access
to all these different
data sets simultaneously.
And once we switched to the test mode,
we do not usually care about
how well they performed
on the previous data sets.
So continual learning seem to be
the most challenging
setting out of all of those,
because it combines
a temporal sequential
nature of learning with
the desire to transfer knowledge,
not only to the future,
but also take care of
not forgetting the past.
And by the way,
a notable important example
related to all the settings
is support out of
distribution generalization,
and you perhaps can view it
as seeking specific setting
of meta-learning as
zero shot meta-learning.
And the classical example comes from the
invariant risk minimization
paper by Arjovsky
and his colleagues at Facebook,
which actually inspired the whole area
of recent robust prediction papers,
which I unfortunately don't
have time to cover here,
but I really encourage you
to take a look at them,
at related work.
And the classical example
is that most of the
modern deep network systems will break,
if they will be asked
to perform on the data
that have distribution
sufficiently different
from the one they were trained on.
For example, if they were
trained to classify animals,
and they only see examples
of cows on green pastures,
and then during tests,
they will certainly see cows on the beach.
Most of the times,
our system performance will
really go down quite a bit,
and there reason is,
there's also another interesting paper,
kind of summarizing this
tendency of deep nets
to rely on so-called shortcut features
or spuriously correlated features,
which do not have really
anything to do with
the concept of animal here,
but they are easier to detect and rely on
such as a green background.
And the goal of our recent approach
is to more and robust out of
distribution generalization,
including that famous paper
by Arjovsky is to figure out,
how to regularize, how
to constrain your model,
and the process of learning it,
so that you will be able to
extract those invariant features.
For example, of animal or a cow,
while ignoring the
spurious shortcut features
such as color of the background.
And there are different
approaches to that, as I said,
it's extremely interesting
and the rapidly growing area,
I encourage you to look into.
But very briefly the idea of CRM
is that you will be aiming
at learning and mapping
from the input from the pixel space
into representation space.
So that essentially it will
be able to learn invariant
or robust set of features there,
so that you can be simultaneously optimal
with this set of features
in terms of predicting
the type of animal across a
variety of different data sets,
or support environments.
And that's kind of the way
the other distribution setting
connects with meta-learning.
At the train time, you will be
given a set of environments,
and your job is to find features
that are robust or invariant,
across all the environments
with respect to predicting
that last label.
Okay.
So back to Continue Learning
Setting, as I mentioned,
the main challenge that
distinguishes this setting
from all the previous
ones that I mentioned,
is it happens online and
it happens sequentially,
and unlike out-of-distribution
or meta-learning type of settings,
you do not have access
to all the previous tasks
when you are switching to a new one.
So what kind of particular
situations can happen here?
So assuming you have access
input-X vector, Y-class label,
and you have the task or
context such as, I don't know,
classifying animals and then
classifying, I don't know,
buildings to classify plants
and so on and so forth.
What can happen here?
You may or may not be told
what task you're doing now.
So the team may be
observed or not observed.
And it also can be observed
both during training and test time or not.
Depending on which of
these conditions satisfied,
you will have several
different type of settings
for our continual learning.
And briefly speaking, if
you observe the task ID,
if you have Oracle telling
you when task changes
during training, it's a simplest case
called task-incremental
continual learning,
well, if that's not the case,
and when the new task arrive,
you will kind of potentially
even have new classes
that will be called
class-incremental continual learning.
And there's also related sitting
called domain-incremental
continual learning.
And when you just not know any
boundary between those tasks,
it's the most challenging
task agnostic settings.
Anyway, I'll probably not going
to have much time to go into
the details, and just give
you the high level idea.
But, as I said, task-incremental
is the simplest setting,
when model is always aware
of which task it's solving.
For example,
it's told that now you will
be classifying animals.
Now you're classifying buildings.
And in this situation it's simple
to have some multi-head architecture
and try to load common representation.
But for each specific task, you
will have its own predictor.
There main assumption here is
just that the set of labels
that you will be predicting in each task
might change across time.
And that's a schematic representation
of what I was just saying.
During training, you have
a clear task boundaries.
And during tests, you also
are told what to classify now,
whether it's like animal
tasks or the building tasks,
and multi-head architecture is a easy way
to handle this problem, essentially.
So what isn't common is
the rest of the network,
which learns good representation across
all these different tasks.
The next more challenging setting
is when you are not given the
task identity during tests,
and that picture kind of
summarizes what's going on,
during training you know
that you are classifying,
say, images in particular tasks,
say, animals and then buildings
and so on and so forth.
While during test, you are
not told where that image,
the test image comes
from a particular task.
You need to figure out
which task it came from
and as well classify properly.
And finally is there is a related
domain-incremental continual learning ,
which only difference
from the previous one
is specific assumption,
and that assumption is that distribution,
and distribution of class
labels does not change.
Just to give you an
example of what it means
in a specific data set.
Imagine you are given the
task of learning a sequence
of split MNIST task.
So first you have to learn
to classify zero from one,
then two from three,
and so on and so forth.
So that's why it's called split MNIST,
because it's splitted into
several separate tasks.
And here is what happens in
each of the three scenarios
that I mentioned.
So with incremental-task learning,
you will be given the task,
you will be told that you
solving task 1 or task 3
or task 5, both during
training and during tests.
And your only question is to figure out,
to answer correctly the question,
whether the image belongs to
the first class or the second,
is it zero or one, or, eight or nine,
but you know the identity of task.
And incremental-domain
learning task is not known,
but you just want to know
whether your class label
belongs to the first or second class,
you need to figure that.
In incremental-class learning,
you also need to figure,
not just whether it's
first or second level,
but which digit it is.
So you also need to figure out which task
that sample came from.
So that's kind of most challenging
task-incremental setting.
You will have to keep
learning all those objects
of different classes,
and the number of pluses keeps increasing.
And finally, as I mentioned,
even more challenging
setting is when the identity
of the task is not given to you,
neither during tests nor during training.
And essentially you may
need to be able to detect
kind of nonstationarity,
detect the change between
the tasks in your data.
There are multiple other
kind of frameworks that were,
and the fittings that kind
of were developed recently,
including method,
meta-continual earning and
continual-meta learning
kind of schematically represented
here, so on and so forth.
And in general the field of
continual learning seem to be
having the explosion of
specific problem settings.
And that's kind of one of the issues,
how to kind of organize them
in some unifying framework.
So, you essentially, I can compare methods
like you can compare apples to oranges.
So you know what exactly your
setting the assumes about
the changes in the environment,
changes in the tasks,
what information is
available to your learner,
and what's the evaluation criteria are?
So there is lots of work in this area,
one particular paper
you could take a look at
from last year and Marius
was trying to unify
these previous settings,
including meta-continual
and continual-meta
in one framework and essentially expand
the meta-learning,
metal learning algorithm,
the famous MAML model,
agnostic meta-learning
to the continual setting
with quite a successful results.
Showing that in that
kind of a general setting
using this approach,
indeed pays off and beats a state over.
Again, I'm unable to go
into all the details,
and encourage you to
look them at this paper.
And once they're back,
just to see what exactly the challenge is,
so we can go to the methods
and see how different classes
or types of approaches try
to attack that challenge.
So essentially what you're
trying to do in this online,
non-stationary continue learning.
As I mentioned, you have
sequence of data distributions
from which data samples were drawn.
Ideally, if you had all
this data available to you,
or you just kept storing
the infinite stream of data,
your natural objective would be
your empirical risk minimization
across all this tasks.
You would have summed the expected risks
for each task across all of them.
Unfortunately, you do not
have access to previous tasks,
either you do a real time
nature of the problem
like in robot learning,
or simply due to the
issue of your inability
to, maybe, just store
infinite amounts of data.
If you intention is to build a system
that can learn lifelong infinitely,
plus sometimes considerations
are basically cost efficiency.
If you running continual
learning agents on edge devices,
on your phone
or on the robot with some
limited memory on it.
It's simply infeasible to
keep all the data accumulated
during the robot lifetime.
And constant communication
with some centralized server
may be also expensive
or not always possible.
So what happens in this
situation, as I mentioned,
the catastrophic forgetting
problem in general
that was observed
in the computational
neuroscience literature,
keeps popping up here.
And the classical example
from the EWC paper
showed that standard
stochastic gradient descent
apply to a sequence of tasks,
will train and do well in the first task,
but the moment it starts
adopting to second task,
information about the previous
task is being washed out,
performance degrades.
The new task is shown
performance keeps degrading
further and further.
Therefore you need to do something,
some form of memory to avoid kind of this
catastrophic forgetting issue
of a naive standard neural net learning
with stochastic gradient.
And essentially this is, as I mentioned,
more general problem of
stability versus plasticity,
which in a sense that I can be viewed
as a program of knowledge
transfer to the future
to perform hopefully better after learning
from several tasks and
lack of interference,
or also kind of positive
transfer to the past,
at least not forgetting how
to do well on previous data
and perhaps even improve your performance.
So that's the ultimate goal.
One common way of measuring
transfer and interference
in various approaches, I'll
mention some of them briefly,
is to simply look at the
dot product of gradients
at their samples from new
tasks and the previous tasks.
And essentially you can
think about that as,
if my current step in
terms of updating based
on my new samples,
goes in the opposite
direction for them over
the direction of the gradient
from the previous task,
I'm kind of forgetting,
I'm kind of making model perform worse
on my previous samples.
So ideally I would like
those gradients to be aligned
and that would facilitate transfer,
while gradients looking in
the opposite directions,
are most likely going to lead
to interference between the task
and that may lead to
catastrophic forgetting.
Just to kind of summarize
possible scenarios
of what can happen with
transfer to the future,
and transfer for not forgetting the past.
There are roughly just five situations
which are nicely described
in the recent survey
from kind of last year
on continual learning,
reference below.
And there are some stations
that are desirable,
and others that you would like to avoid.
So too bad situations are forgetting,
as we already mentioned,
when performance on the
earlier tasks keeps degrading.
But another also bad situation
is when you're too stable
and you lack plasticity.
So you learn the first task
and perform well on that,
but you are unable to learn anything new.
On the contrary,
good situations would
be when either you have
both stability plasticity
and you keep performing
as well as you did on previous task
while learning new tests.
Possibly, learning
previous tasks helps you
to actually improve
learning of the new task.
It's even positive, forward transfer,
and the ideal situation is
not just positive forward,
but also positive backward transfer,
when learning new tasks helps
you to even perform better
on the previous one.
So that's what can happen.
What really happens in
practice mainly depends on
both data properties
and method properties.
And right now,
I just want to say that the
field of continual learning
is quite empirical.
There is a proliferation
of different approaches,
and there is a clear lack
of theoretical understanding
of what works when, and where?
So just to give you some
high level overview,
I want to mention,
as I kind of alluded to it before,
talking about neuroscientific
inspirations replay methods,
as you remember this support
memory-based replay methods.
I assume that you will replay
or somehow keep some
representative samples
of previous tasks,
and that will help you
to not completely forget
the information about the previous tasks
while adapting to new ones.
So another approach is not
to keep any kind of samples
in memory,
but really trying to operate
on the weights that you learn.
And that's the second category
of support regularization based methods.
As I mentioned before, in
your science inspirations,
they relate to this idea that
when we learn a certain tasks,
particular weights,
particular synapsis are
assigned to those tasks.
And we may want to protect those weights
from future changes,
when learning new tasks.
So there is a whole class of
approach based on this idea.
And finally, again,
very roughly kind of along the
lines of neurogenetic ideas
from neuroscience, that are
so-called architecture based
or parameter isolation methods,
where you are allowed to
expand your architecture,
if needed, to accommodate the new tasks,
and the need to represent
more information.
Again, we don't have much time remaining,
and I will only very, very
briefly kind of give you
the taxonomy of those
methods with a few examples.
You are very welcome to
read this a third way
that I'm citing here, right.
The launch at our continual learning,
at the end of this lecture,
I will also give you a list
of other recent tutorials.
As I mentioned,
the number of methods proposed
recently is really large,
and keeps growing very rapidly.
So replay methods have several subtypes,
kind of based on this
rehearsal of pseudo rehearsals
or not storing the exact
samples from the past,
but rather generating them
from some generative models
with a constrained methods.
I have a few examples,
and I apologize for really
going extremely quickly,
our gradient episodic memory paper,
very nice one based on the
constraint that you want
the gradients of old
and new kind of samples
to at least not contradict each other.
Therefore the constraint at the bottom,
that product of the gradients
should be non-negative
at that point a generated
state about results.
Later on, meta-experience replay approach
in the same category.
You use replay previous
samples to keep information
from representative information
from previous tasks.
You use the idea of
gradient alignment as well,
but here you make it
part of your objective,
rather than just a constraint
and you actually beat
the previous method, and some others.
And again, this is not
the most recent method,
there are even better ones
right now, so on and so forth.
Generative replay,
where instead of storing
samples of previous tasks,
you rather build generative models,
which can generate representative samples
and add those to our current data set.
So basically so-called pseudo rehearsal
or generative replay type of methods.
And there are many
approaches along this line.
Again, I highly recommend this
recent paper by van de Van,
on this type of approaches.
There is second class, roughly
speaking, besides the replay,
the regularization based methods.
And there are many of them,
again, you're welcome to
look at the survey listed
at the bottom of the page.
Classical examples,
is a famous elastic weight
consolidation paper from 2017,
which by now is of course out performed
by many recent approaches,
but it's a classical benchmark
for various comparisons.
And the idea there was precisely motivated
by the the synaptic
consolidation inspiration
from neuroscience,
that you try to protect the weights
that are most important
for learning previous task
from changes imposed while
you're adapting to new tasks,
which way you do it precisely
through regularization
and details.
You can see in the paper,
there is a whole bunch of
approaches along the same lines,
which different terms of
what regularizer you use,
the idea of protecting the
specific weights is common.
And again,
the classical picture that
is often used to demonstrate
how to avoid catastrophic forgetting,
forgetting is this one.
Finally the so-called parameter isolation
or architectural approaches methods
also have several sub classes,
some fixed network architecture,
but try to pack the
weights for different tasks
into different parts of the network,
while others actually
expand the architecture.
And the list of methods here is quite long
from the relatively
simplistic Packnet paper,
where the network is fixed and
you kind of try to allocate
sparse subsets of weights
to different tasks.
And then you keep kind of
learning the remaining ones
for the new tasks.
And essentially, yeah,
this approach has some advantages
over just fix that works.
And the second type of work was expanding
architecture's progressive networks,
but a kind of on the add
fixed number of neurons,
while in this method of
dynamic expendable networks,
they were really being smart
about how many new neurons
to add, so on and so forth.
There are many interesting
papers along those lines.
There are very different
style of approaches,
still falling into the
category of architectural.
For example,
I really liked this neural
dirichlet process paper,
essentially, they use their
kind of Bayesian approach
to building sub-networks or experts.
And only introducing a new one,
when the data cannot be explained
well by the previous ones
and they show how to apply it
in continual learning setting.
Yet another approach directly motivated
by neurogenesis ideas,
I mentioned it with
other paper awhile ago,
on essentially
how to expand and compress
if needed hidden layers
so that you will adapt to
changing sequence of tasks.
But at the same time,
you avoid extending the model infinitely,
an analogy of this human neurogenesis
is that we have the birth of
new neurons in hippocampus,
but we also have deaths of
neurons that are not being used.
And essentially if the
complexity of environment
is relatively low,
there are not much neurogenesis
on you neurons is remaining,
essentially ,it's kind
of use it or lose it,
type of a situation.
And indeed,
if you show a sufficiently
rich and changing
set of environments to your model
or an empirical neuroscientific
papers to your animal
like I put brat into a reach
and changing environment,
more neurogenesis happens
and also performance on the
kind of continual learning
type of tasks is better.
So that's what we also
observed with our kind of our
simple autoencoder model,
which in the neurogenetic
setting was ending up with models
that were always adapting
better to new data
and not forgetting old data.
While same size but fixed size
models were not as flexible,
as were kind of found empirically,
essentially supporting
the empirical observations
from those neuroscience
papers on neurogenesis.
Anyways, so just kind of
to conclude this whole idea
of expanding networks
and growing architecture
with some higher level view
of what the role of
continual learning could be,
as you might've heard,
there is lots of discussions
and papers along the lines of
compositionality and
recombinations of certain
basic independent components or mechanisms
in order to improve models,
generalization to say
out-of-distribution type of data
and so on.
So the idea here could be
that exposing your model
to challenging, diverse
and complex environments
in continual learning setting,
can be a method for
producing this expanding set
of the core mechanisms
that can be recombined
to solve any problem that will
come your way in the future.
If you assume that all those
datasets problems or tasks
are from the world that
continual learning agents
should live in.
If they allow for some final basis,
because each problem
in supervised learning
can be seen as a function
approximation problem.
If this set of functions
can be well approximated
in some finite basis,
by certain recombination
of this basis functions,
then you have a hope of
learning finite network
that can deal with infinite set of tasks,
as long as they they're
coming from the world with the
properties that I just mentioned.
Somewhat similar to how we
develop the finite size brain
with certain components responsible
for different, somewhat, orthogonal tasks,
motor visual, auditory.
And recombination of those allows us
to successfully solve
many different problems.
I know I'm running a
little bit out of time,
but I just wanted to very
briefly mentioned this new,
and most challenging and exciting field
of continual reinforcement learning,
which is as I said,
more challenging than supervised learning,
because you have agent actively
affecting the environment
in which this agent acts,
without too much detail,
I would refer you to already
recent survey on continual RL.
And essentially it goes
over different sources
of non-stationary care and
different types of them,
whether it depends on
the environment only,
or environment is also
affected by actions of agent.
And that was a non-stationarity
or combinations of that,
it gives taxonomy of existing approaches
to continual reinforcement learning.
And it discusses a desirable
properties of benchmarks
because it seemed to be one of
the key important components
of making continual reinforcement
learning successful.
How to design sufficiently
challenging benchmarks.
Also in some controlled
ways that you can increase
their complexity and you control that,
and so on and so forth.
It also discusses different metrics
way beyond just cumulative reward
that you would like
your agent to optimize.
And that's kind of interesting
food for thought as well,
when you develop new
methods, so on and so forth.
It discusses open problems
in particular this area
and inspirations from neuroscience
that you could borrow,
just building upon the previous successes
of neural inspired approaches
and continual learning.
And the final point that
I just wanted to make,
oh, two final points,
very briefly is this is
kind of just advertisement
of recently developed
a unifying framework,
a library for different
settings methods on
kind of continual learning problems,
including supervised and
reinforcement learning
called Sequoia.
Yeah, if you're interested I
can always provide you a link
of GitHub, it's an open source,
and you're welcome to use
it and build on top of that.
It was developed by students at Mila,
Fabrice, Normandin, and Massimo
are large group of people
working with them during the past year.
And finally, an open question.
There is lots of
discussions recently about
the role of scaling in neural networks,
especially motivated by
recent successes of GPT-3.
And there is one of the
recent talks along those lines
about explaining neural
scaling laws, by the way,
for those of you who are not
yet familiar with this area,
the scaling laws are empirical
kind of observations about
how various neural net
architectures behave
on different types of tasks,
with increasing data set,
size, model size, and compute.
and what align empirically has
been found in the past year
that most of the times
they follow power laws.
But the question is what
properties of algorithms and models
make those power laws converge
faster to smaller error,
which ones are better.
There is a hypothesis being discussed,
whether scaling neural net models
can maybe solve continual learning
and just get rid of
forgetting program completely.
There's some promising results,
but in very limited
setting with a few tasks.
Oh, as you expect, larger models
should have more capacity,
and yes, eventually they
can incorporate both tasks,
or even like 10 tasks like
mentioned in the talk.
But the question is, is
there a limit to that?
And it seems that besides
scaling your model
and the data you train on,
you should probably
consider another dimension,
which can be a complexity of
continual learning environment,
in a sense of how diverse the tasks are.
And if you push that complexity
of environment further,
I bet that there must be some trade-off
between that complexity and
the capacity of your model
and size of your model.
And it would be interesting
to know what the trade off is.
So you may need to scale
model beyond certain level
to capture certain complexity
of the environment.
And totally a speculative
slide is that perhaps
to truly capture continual
learning the way humans do it,
we may need to even go beyond
the modern artificial neural
network kind of designs,
and not just to allow
for growing neural networks standard way,
but maybe new types of neural networks,
may be richer networks
allowing for extra capacity,
for example,
the representing time perhaps or not,
that's an open question.
So I will conclude here
by listing the ultimate
wishlist of properties of
continual learning systems.
And I also refer you to
various recent surveys,
as I mentioned on the topic,
and I'm pretty sure more surveys
being written as we speak.
And thank you very much for more details.
You can also take a look
at our recent ICML tutorial
on the same subject.
Thank you-
- Amazing Irina,
thank you so much for
just this just extensive
and thorough survey of continual learning.
I learned so much, I'm a
neuroscientist by training.
And so I was really
inspired by what you shared,
how the insights from
neuroscience are being applied
to this field and
the state of the art
and the open questions,
I think this is really, really
exciting area of research.
We have a ton of questions
that have come in.
I do remind our participants
to upvote rather than
enter your own questions.
Irina we'll be able to answer
a few of them, offline.
So we'll share these with
her after the lecture,
and we'll even try to stay
maybe for a total of five
minutes for the Q&A right now.
Irina, and so let's try to do
some of the most popular
questions right off the bat.
And so the first question is
to ask you to share with us
a few examples of unsupervised
continual learning.
- Well, one example is
Karol paper a few years ago,
basically on stochastic learning.
But you can think about in
a sense that it's nothing...
There are several references,
I'll be happy to provide
the list of papers,
but in a sense, if you
think about trying to learn,
say distribution of the
data that incorporates
multiple different sub
distributions, roughly speaking,
there is nothing too specific
to their supervised setting.
I mean,
you can think about
trying to capture variety
of data distributions in one model,
and those data distributions
will be responding to
unsupervised setting where you would like
to model your samples and be able
to reconstruct them accurately.
Yeah. So in a sense, it's not
surprising that there is this,
the field is just a bit less explored
just because of the of
supervised learning.
But, yeah, I'd be happy to
provide more references.
The paper Karol is like one
example that come to mind-
- Sure. Yeah, we can just append
those to your Q&A document,
that's fine-
- And the ICML tutorial by the way,
the second part of it
given by me and Ms. Sensa.
She talked a bit more
on unsupervised continual
learning, exactly.
So if you follow that link
and go to the part two,
you'll find more there.
- Okay, great. That's a
really helpful resource.
Okay, the next question is,
"in a supervised setting,
how can the imbalance in
the number of data samples
per task impact the learning?"
- Class imbalance is
always a potential issue.
I think, I mean, there is no specific
continual learning related consideration
that kind of really just like
with usual supervised learning,
if you have high class imbalance,
you might not be able
to represent properly
as a second class,
so you will need to do
something about that.
And yeah, so I don't think
that continual learning adds
any extra complexity.
So any method that you would
use to handle class imbalance,
perhaps can be incorporated
in the continual learning setting.
- Great. Okay.
That's great advice.
Next question,
"How much does the curriculum matter
in a continual learning setup?
To design a curriculum,
how would we go about creating
a suitable set of scaffolds
to learn effectively?"
- Yeah. This is a great question
and yes, it matters a lot.
And indeed, I mean, especially with, yeah,
with sufficiently different
distributions of data
in different tasks,
again, the recitations,
when gradual kind of
increase of complexity
by slowly changing the task distribution
may be better for model learn,
instead of the drastic change.
But it also depends on your approach
and service drastic changes.
Certain methods such
as maybe architectural
that allow for expanding the architecture
who are good at detecting
the changes drastic
and introducing, and constructing
a new part of the model.
Those might work better
if actually you designed
the curriculum to be more challenging
and the changes are more
abrupt, but in general,
yes, it's highly relevant question.
It's often empirical.
The answers are frequently empirical.
You need to investigate
for which type of methods
and models, what type of
curricula might be best.
but in general, in general,
the rule of thumb is that curriculum
should be sufficiently challenging.
If you would like to develop a
model that is more versatile.
And definitely if you use
some very basic benchmarks
such as rotated or permuted the MNIST,
this is not enough of curriculum
to learn truly generalizing models.
- It has to be more complex than that.
It's great.
Okay, so last question that we
have time for to answer live,
"How does continual learning
relate to the online learning
literature?"
- Yeah, I mean, it relates directly.
So you essentially can think
about continual learning as
online non-stationary learning.
It is online learning,
but the classical online
learning typically assumes
that the data stream comes
from the same distribution,
while continuing learning
assumes that there will be change points,
whether abrupt or some kind of drifts.
And that's the main difference between
classical online learning
and non-stationary or
continual online learning.
- It's a lot more dynamic in
the continual learning context,
right. Great.
Okay. So I'm afraid.
That's all we have time for, but Irina,
what a wonderful lecture.
Thank you so much for such a deep dive,
such a thorough examination of the topic.
We really enjoyed it-
- Thank you.
(gentle spirited music)